[Music]
you will emerge today's episode a new
American Dream what separates man from
Beast
[Music]
no it's not his ability to tap-dance it
is his desire to build after
thermonuclear war man's towering
industrial marvels may no longer stretch
to the heavens it then falls on you and
the ingenuity of your fellows to rebuild
the America we hold dear get started
with camp the construction and assembly
mobile platform
it's the workbench of tomorrow once
established your camp will not only
provide you with much-needed shelter but
also the means to satisfy your hunger
quench your thirst and even treat
infection the essential pillars of
survival expand your camp by scavenging
resources or mining raw materials the
old-fashioned way
[Music]
then construct your home of the future
[Music]
if your first home site is undesirable
use your handy camp to move it to a
better location with your home secure
you can now craft handmade ordnance at
your leisure to give your altercations
that personal touch
or better yet sell these homemade
implements to your neighbors for profit
remember capitalism it's the only thing
keeping us from being communists the
world may have ended but keeping up with
the Joneses has not use those
hard-earned profits to upgrade your
dwelling when your home looks important
you are important now you've learned how
to forge the new American dream
you are completely prepared to rebuild
the greatest nation in the world as a
hand-picked resident of vault 76 it is
your duty to carefully review your
vault-tec provided films yearly to fully
prepare for the day when you will emerge
you
play the beta first on Xbox one
[Music]